identifica 15 octavos es una fracción
propia o impropia así es que este vídeo
es un muy buen repaso recordemos que una
fracción es propia si el numerador
recordemos que este es el numerador
y este de acá es el denominador
y una fracción es propia si su numerador
es más chico que su denominador o sea si
el numerador es más chico es menor
estricto que su denominador todo esto es
si es una fracción
propia habrá una fracción es impropia si
su numerador es mayor o igual que su
denominador osea que su numerador puede
ser exactamente igual a su denominador o
más grande para hacer que la fracción
sea impropia
y bueno en realidad aquí nos faltó
especificar algo y esto funciona muy
bien así tal cual como está si estos
números el numerador y el denominador
son ambos positivos pero si tienes aquí
algún signo negativo lo que tienes que
recordar es que aquí estamos tomando
valores absolutos entonces una fracción
es propia si el valor absoluto de su
numerador es más chico es menor estricto
que el valor absoluto de su denominador
y lo mismo para las impropias o sea una
fracción es impropia si el valor
absoluto de su numerador es mayor o
igual que el valor absoluto de su
denominador entonces regresando a
nuestro problema quince octavos pues
tenemos que 15 es mayor estricto que 8
que bueno si eso pasa entonces 15 es
mayor o igual que 8 y eso lo que implica
es que 15 octavos es una fracción
impropia